- [Instructor] Let's
say we have the function
F of X is equal to X to the sixth,
minus three X to the fifth.
And my question to you
is using only what we
know about derivatives.
Try to figure out over
what interval or intervals
is this function decreasing?
Pause the video and
try to figure that out.
All right, now let's do this together.
So we know that a function is decreasing
when its derivative is negative.
Or another way to say it,
It's going to be decreasing
when F prime of X
is less than zero.
So what is F prime of X?
Well, we could use the derivative rules
and drew the properties we know.
We apply the power rule
to X, to the sixth,
We bring the six out front
or multiply the one coefficient here,
times six, to get six,
X to the fifth
detriment that exponent,
minus bring the five times the three
minus 15, X to the,
we detriment the five,
so X to the fourth.
And we need to figure out
over what intervals is this
going to be less than zero.
And now let's see how we can
simplify this a little bit.
Both of these terms are
divisible by X to the fourth,
and they're both divisible by three.
So let's factor out a
three X to the fourth
times, you factor out of
three X to the fourth year,
you're left with a two X,
and then over here you have minus five
has to be less than zero.
Any interval where this is true,
we are going to be decreasing.
Now, how do we get this
to be less than zero?
Well, if I take the product of two things
and it's less than zero,
that means that they have
to have different signs,
either one's positive
and the other's negative
or one's negative and
the other's positive.
So we have two situations.
So we could say either,
either, three X to the fourth
is greater than zero
and, and two X minus five
is less than zero.
So that's one situation.
I'll do some in a different color,
or I'll do this one in a different color,
three X to the fourth is less than zero
and two X minus five
is greater than zero.
Actually let me stay on
the second case first.
Are there any situations
where three X to the fourth
can be less than zero?
You take any number,
you take it to the fourth power
even if it's a negative,
it's going to become a positive.
So you can't get a negative
expression right over here.
So actually the second condition
is impossible to obtain.
You can't get any situation for any X
where three X to the
fourth is less than zero.
So we can rule this one out.
And so this is our best hope.
So under what conditions
is three X to the fourth,
greater than zero.
Well, if you divide both sides by three,
you get X to the fourth
is greater than zero.
And if you think about it,
this is gonna be true for any X value
that is not equal to zero.
Even if you have a negative value there,
if you have a negative one,
you take it to the fourth
power becomes a positive one.
Only zero will be equal to zero
when you take it to the fourth power.
So one way we could say this
is going to be true for any non zero X,
or we could just say,
X does not equal zero,
and, this is a little
bit more straightforward,
we add five to both sides
we get two X is less than five,
divide both sides by two,
you get X is less than five halves.
So it might be tempting to say, all right,
the intervals that matter are
all the exes less than five halves,
but X cannot be equal to zero.
Now, is that the entire interval
where our function is decreasing?
Well, let's think about
what happens at zero itself.
We're decreasing over the
interval from negative infinity
all the way up to zero.
And we're also decreasing
from zero to five halves.
And so for decreasing
right to the left of zero,
we're decreasing right
to the right of zero,
we're actually going to
be decreasing at zero
at we're also gonna be
decreasing at zero as well.
So there's something interesting here,
even though the derivative
at X equals zero,
is going to be equal to zero,
we are still decreasing.
And so the interval that we care about
the interval over which we're decreasing
is just X is less than five halves.
And we can see that by
graphing the function,
I graphed it on Desmos,
and you can see here
that the function is decreasing
from negative infinity,
it's decreasing at a
slower and slower rate
we get to zero still
decreasing to the left of zero,
and then it continues to
decrease to the right of zero.
So any, any value, any X
value to the left of zero
the value of the function is going to be
larger than F of zero,
and X to the right of zero.
The value of the function is going to be
less than the function at zero.
So it's actually decreasing through zero,
even though the slope of the
tangent line at zero is zero,
even though it's non negative
and then we keep decreasing
so we're decreasing for all values of X,
less than five halves,
which you can see visually here.